okay top Tech is on display in Barcelona
this week as the Spanish City hosts the
annual Mobile World Congress it's where
the world's biggest Wireless company
show off their very latest designs and
this year they have foldable smartphones
and AI powered chat Bots that nearly
have minds of their own it's also the
first year the event is back to full
strength since the covid-19 pandemic and
our very own Charlie Angela is there for
us live in Barcelona Charlie so what's
everyone excited about this year
well first I've got to apologize for
being outside instead of inside but the
sheer number of devices that are
connected inside means that we couldn't
get connectivity in there but inside
it's all about the future and over the
next four days some 80 000 people from
over 200 different countries are going
to be looking at the products and the
technology that are going to shape that
future and you're right in saying that
this event started as one showcasing
mobile phones but now that mobile phone
design and development has pretty much
plateaued it's those Wireless
technologies that are taking over so
we'll see the launch of a few foldable
phones from some Chinese companies but
really the buzzers around the tech that
you can't hold the metaverse which is
essentially the internet in 3D and
generative AI like chat gbt which is
creating very human-like content and has
certain industries like advertising
copywriting and some journalists
slightly quaking in their
yeah tell us tell us a little more about
the metaverse to people not so familiar
about it what is the future looking like
well it seems after a very Rocky 2022 in
which uh the company meta said it was
reducing its investment in the
technology it's really now becoming more
of a reality and we're hearing that 88
of global companies have invested in
some way or another in this kind of
Virtual Technology so here we're seeing
lots of companies showcasing their
latest online avatars ways for to
transform shopping gaming socializing
work by creating virtual conference
rooms but also even things like travel
where you can mimic a hotel in the
virtual world experience it and work out
if that's somewhere you actually want to
stay but I think what's really
interesting here is the companies that
are demonstrating the development in
What's called the industrial metaverse
and that's something that we won't see
as consumers but it is happening and
that is where real machines factories
buildings cities even transfer
deportation grids and electricity hubs
are being created also in the virtual
world creating essentially a digital
twin now the idea is that in a digital
environment the programmers can identify
any problems any issues that can arise
they can increase production and and
that is what's going to be Transforming
Our Lives but behind the scenes really
interesting to talk to you Charlie
Angela there for us at the Mobile World
Congress in Barcelona